[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
SARAH HEWETT: All right,
let's get started.
And if anybody else shows
up, then that'll be fine.
So today, we are going
to talk about how
to write a lab report, which
is a pretty important part
of this course, since
it's going to determine
a good portion of your grade.
And in general,
it's good to know
how to communicate the
science that you do,
whether it's in this
class or in your research,
or in any other context, really.
So I wanted to start just
by thinking about these two
questions, which is why is
it important to write up
your results, and then how
should you write a lab report?
And to help get us thinking
about these questions,
I printed out on
this handout that
has a good chunk of text on it.
The top part is Ira
Remsen's account
of his experiment with
copper and nitric acid.
If you have not read it before,
it's a pretty good read.
So if you could skim that.
And then at the bottom, there
is a shorter description
of the same experiment
in a way that you
may find it written
either in a lab report
or in a scientific
paper if you were
going to publish these results.
So if you guys want to
give those a quick skim
through, and then
we'll use those
to sort of talk about
these topics of how do
you communicate your science.
And if you've never seen
this experiment done before,
I have a little bit
of video to show
what happens when you put
nitric acid on a penny.
So you can have an
even more vivid visual
of what Ira Remsen
was going through when
he decided to pick this up
and throw it out a window.
NARRATOR: A few
drops of nitric acid
are placed on an
older copper penny.
SARAH HEWETT: And
it goes for a while.
So that should give you a little
bit of an idea of the situation
that he was in.
And so having had a chance
to skim these two things,
does anyone have any answers
to these questions about
why is it important to write
up your results, or how
should you communicate your
results to other people?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So it's,
like, not ambiguous,
so people know what
to expect or they know
how to handle the situation.
[INAUDIBLE] oh, let's see
what happens [INAUDIBLE]
SARAH HEWETT: Yeah, using
really clear language,
so that people know
what is going to happen.
Like he said, the language
acts upon is very vague.
And it led to this
experiment happening
where Ira Remsen burned his
hands on some nitric acid.
So instead of acts
upon, saying things
like-- what else
could you say instead?
What are better words you
could use to warn people
of what's going to happen?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Corrosive.
SARAH HEWETT: Yeah, corrosive.
Those things that Scott talked
about in his safety lecture.
So say some of the
general terms that we
use to describe chemicals.
It's corrosive, it will
burn, creates toxic gases,
is carcinogenic,
things like that.
What other guidelines
should there
be for how you want
your results written up?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Indicate amounts,
because of the [INAUDIBLE]
SARAH HEWETT: Yeah,
yeah, definitely.
You want to communicate
how much you used.
So in that first
experiment, he said
I put some nitric
acid on a penny.
So you don't know
what scale that
was on or what scale it
can be safely done at.
So using exact quantities,
so that if somebody
is going to redo
the experiment, they
would know exactly
how much you used
and what they should expect.
In terms of the length of
these two pieces of writing,
which one is easier to read?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SARAH HEWETT: The bottom one
so being clear and concise,
using objective,
short sentences,
so that people can follow
what you're writing.
And they don't have to read
this whole, huge chunk of text
in order to get the
gist of what's going on.
So those are some things to
keep in mind while writing up
your lab report.
There's a picture of Ira Remsen.
He was a chemist in the 1800s.
He was born in 1846.
And he became the president
of Johns Hopkins University,
and also is well-known for
discovering the sweetener
saccharin, which
he also discovered
by tasting it on his hands as
a result of some more poor lab
technique.
I mean, he became pretty famous.
But don't follow his lead
necessarily in that way.
So a good lab report starts
before the lab even begins.
And so here are
some things that you
should be keeping in mind before
you even come into the lab
to help set you up to be able to
do the experiment successfully,
and to be able to have the data
that you need to write a lab
report.
So you want to plan
your procedures ahead
of time, things that can
influence your results, what
quantities you need
to measure, and what
data and results you'll need to
collect, so that you can have
all of this in your notebook,
so that when you go to write up
your report you have all of
the information that you need.
It's very hard to
go back into the lab
and write something down
that you forgot after you're
in your dorm room at 10:00 PM
the night before the lab's due,
going, oh no.
How much did this weigh?
So you want to plan
out ahead of time
what you're going
to need to collect.
There are a bunch of
parts to the lab report.
And this looks
slightly overwhelming,
but it's actually there to
help you organize your thoughts
and present things in a
format that other people can
recognize.
So if you've ever written a
report for another course,
or if you've read scientific
articles in the literature,
these titles may seem
pretty familiar to you.
You guys have written reports
for other classes before, yes?
Read articles,
most of you, maybe?
OK, so we're going to go through
these parts of the lab report,
and talk about in detail
what belongs in each section.
And we're going to try
to do that in the context
of the ferrocene
experiment to help you
guys plan out your report for
the one you're going to have
to write starting next week.
Hopefully, you've
already started
the little pieces of it.
So the first thing is the title.
That's usually pretty boring.
Keep it straight to the point.
Have something to do with what
the experiment that you did is.
And then the first
thing that you're
going to write after the
title is the abstract.
And the abstract that you
guys are probably pretty
familiar with is very short.
It's three to four sentences.
Keep it in complete
sentences, though.
And then you discuss the
point of the experiment.
You briefly tell what you
did and what you found.
You can talk about
your results--
if you have any
yields, melting points,
easily digestible results
that you can put at the end.
So for your ferrocene,
you would say,
I synthesized ferrocene
this many grams,
this was its melting point--
something like that.
And the abstract is best written
at the end of your report.
So after you've done
everything else,
then you can go back
and write the abstract,
because the abstract
is essentially
just a short summary of
everything else you've written.
So if all the other
stuff is there,
then you can look
at each section,
take a sentence out of
it, smush it all together,
and then you have your abstract.
So then after your abstract,
on the start in the guidelines
for how to format this and
how to write everything
are in your lab manuals.
So you should
definitely look at those
while you were preparing
your lab report.
And it'll tell you that,
after the abstract that
goes on your first
page, the start
of the second page
of the lab report
is going to be
your introduction.
And the introduction
should probably
be about a page or
two long give or take,
depending on the experiment
and how much you need
to introduce ahead of time.
And you're going to tell the
reader what you plan to do
and why they should
care about it.
Give any background
that is necessary-- so
any historic background,
any scientific background,
experiments that have
come before this one that
influenced your work.
Include balanced
chemical equations
of important reactions.
This is very important.
So if you're going to be
doing some sort of chemical
reaction, which in this
lab we did-- we did two,
then you should include the
balanced chemical equation
for the work that
you're planning to do.
And then also, any
fundamental mathematical
equations that you plan to
use to analyze your data.
In this case, we don't
have so many in this lab.
But in future labs,
like the catalase lab
when you're doing
kinetics, you'll
have a lot more
mathematical equations
that you're going to
need to use and explain
to your reader at
the beginning, so
that they know what's coming.
And then you want to discuss
any important techniques
and why you need to
use them in the lab--
their relevance
to the experiment
that you are planning to do.
So with this in mind,
let's brainstorm
what might go in the
introduction of your ferrocene
reports.
So you can think about
the ferrocene lecture
from Tuesday, stuff you've
done in the lab so far.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Like, how
it was discovered,
and how it launched the
transition metal chemistry.
SARAH HEWETT: Yeah.
The discovery and
history of ferrocene
and other organometallic
chemistry.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Relevant
uses of ferrocene.
SARAH HEWETT: Yeah,
You guys performed the
acetylation of ferrocene.
So why do we care that you
can add different groups
to the ferrocene rings?
It's a good thing to mention.
So we've got some historic
and scientific background.
What else can we put in there?
AUDIENCE: Like,
synthesis of ferrocene.
So like, the equation's
of the organic molecules.
SARAH HEWETT: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And also the
acetylation of ferrocene.
SARAH HEWETT: Yeah,
chemical equations
for ferrocene and
acetylferrocene.
We got our balanced
chemical equations.
Do we have any mathematical
equations that we need?
No?
Now, what techniques
might you talk about?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
sublimation.
SARAH HEWETT: Yeah, sublimation.
AUDIENCE: Inert
atmosphere [INAUDIBLE]
SARAH HEWETT: Yeah,
inert air-free technique.
Yes.
You want to talk
about that and why
we care about that
in relation to what
could happen to the
different components
of our ferrocene synthesis.
What other techniques?
AUDIENCE: Thin layer
chromatography.
SARAH HEWETT: Yeah, TLC.
And?
AUDIENCE: Column.
SARAH HEWETT: And the column.
Running out of room.
Yeah, TLC and column
chromatography.
So how are you going to purify
your products when you're done.
Yes, anything else?
AUDIENCE: Filtration?
SARAH HEWETT: Yeah, we
can talk about filtration,
how you're going to isolate your
products during the synthesis.
AUDIENCE: Measuring a melting
point calibration [INAUDIBLE]
SARAH HEWETT: Yeah,
melting point.
Melting point and how you can
use the melting point analysis.
So what does the
melting point tell you?
What information are
we getting from that?
Why are we taking
melting points?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Purity.
SARAH HEWETT: It'll tell
you the purity, yeah.
So you can compare it to
the literature values,
and you can look at the
width of the melting range
to see how pure
your compound is.
So all of these
things are good things
that you can discuss
in your introduction.
And you don't need to go
into crazy amounts of detail,
but you want to give enough
detail that the reader will
know why those are important
for your particular experiment.
Good.
So a note on including
equations in a lab report.
We said that you need to include
any mathematical or chemical
equations that are going to
be used in the introduction.
And the way that
you do this is you
give each equation a number.
And when you write
it in your report,
you'll write either
the chemical equation
or a mathematical equation.
And then over to the
right in parentheses,
you'll number them.
And you'll number them in order.
And you can either number
them both, the chemical
and the mathematical
equations, sequentially.
So any equation, no
matter what kind it is,
just go one, two,
three all the way down.
Or if you want, you
can separate and have
one of the types of equations
be in just regular numbers,
and then the other
one in Roman numerals.
Both formats are acceptable.
And if you have any
questions about how
to do any of the
formatting things I'm
going to talk to you about, it's
all from the ACS Style Guide.
So we have these books in the
lab if you want to borrow one.
There's some information
online as well,
or you can talk to
me or John or the TAs
if you have questions
and can't find anything.
But that's where all of
the information for how
to format things from this
presentation are coming from.
So we're going to use ACS
formatting for everything.
And then the important thing
is that equations and anything
else that you add, like
tables and figures--
and we'll talk about
those in a little bit,
they can't stand on their own.
You must reference
them in the text.
So you can't just throw an
equation up here and not
talk about it.
You'll have to throw in
a sentence that says,
the reaction of copper nitric
acid as shown in equation 1.
So the next part is
procedures and observations.
So this includes what you
actually did in the lab.
And the really important
thing about this
is that it has to match what
is in your lab notebook.
So we already gave you
an idealized version
of the procedure--
an idea of how you're
supposed to be doing it.
But we want to know
what actually happened
when you did the experiment.
So if you accidentally added
twice as much cyclopentodiene
as you were supposed to,
write that in your procedure.
Don't just re-copy what
is in the lab notebook.
Draw a diagram of any specialty
glassware that you used.
So you don't need to
tell us piece by piece
how you assembled
your glassware.
You can just draw
a picture and say,
I set up a distillation
as shown in figure 1.
And that's all you need to do.
Then you need to give
enough information
for one of your classmates
to recreate the procedure.
So again, you don't need to
go into excruciating detail
about how you injected
things out of a syringe.
Assume that one of your
classmates is reading this,
and they have the same
knowledge that you do.
So if you say, I used a
syringe to measure this,
or a syringe was used,
because you're not
supposed to use
pronouns, then that would
be enough information for one of
us to recreate the experiment.
Include all the information
about a chemical
with the correct precision.
So when you're
measuring-- and we'll
talk about this next
week in our lecture,
about the different
precision of glassware,
you want to include all
relevant significant figures.
So if you're measuring
something that
has more than one
decimal place, include
all of the decimal places.
So 5.2 milliliters of 8
molar nitric acid was added,
not just 5 milliliters
of added in--
if there's any specific
way that you added things--
like when you guys
added your aliquots,
you did 0.25
milliliters at a time,
you want to include
that so that people
don't add it all at once--
something like that.
Or if you add
something drop-wise,
make sure that's included.
And then you want to
give brief observations
about the color, texture,
and state of matter
of your product.
So you can say, I formed 5
grams of a white powder--
something like
that, just so that,
again, when the reader's
are doing the lab,
if they get a white powder, they
want to know is this correct?
Yes.
And then if there are
any safety concerns that
are relevant or
unusual, those can also
go in your procedure
and observation section.
So again, thinking
about ferrocene,
what are you going to write
out the procedures of?
What was the first
thing that we did?
I guess not even
that you guys did.
Cracking the cyclopentodiene.
So even though you guys didn't
do that necessarily yourselves,
that was an important
part of the procedure.
So you should include cracking
the cyclopentodiene monomer.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
SARAH HEWETT: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Like with the examples
where we draw the figures.
So if we're drawing the chemical
equation for the [INAUDIBLE]
or drawing
sublimation, do we just
scan those into the lab report?
SARAH HEWETT: Yeah,
so if you're going
to be drawing any pictures
of glassware or chemical
equations, you can handwrite
them and scan them in,
and insert them as pictures
into your lab report
if that's easier.
You can also use, for
chemical equations especially,
ChemDraw if you have access
to that on a lab computer.
Or there's some free versions,
like MarvinSketch or ChemDoodle
that you can find online
that will give you
the actual chemical
structures that you can draw.
And then you can just
copy and paste those
into your lab report.
And also, if you
have ChemDraw, it
has a glassware feature,
where you can actually build
different glassware setups.
So you can build the
distillation in there
if you wanted do.
But yeah, if you
handwrite anything,
like equations or pictures,
you can scan those in
and insert them as a picture.
So once you crack the Cp,
what was the next big part
of the procedure.
First thing you made.
We'll just call it
synthesis of ferrocene--
of ferrocene.
So that would be, yeah,
preparing the KOH.
Preparing the iron chloride.
Mixing them together.
Shaking for who knows how long.
And then your filtration
and your isolation
of the ferrocene.
Then the next thing was the
synthesis of acetylferrocene,
which some of you have done,
and some of you will do today.
And then what are we doing
next week, in the last day?
TLC.
The important parts of
that are running the TLC,
and also choosing your solvent.
So you want to make
sure that you include
both of those things in there.
And then what's the
last thing we're going
to do to purify the product?
Column chromatography.
So you'll have a bunch
of different parts
to the procedure for this
lab, and for most of the labs
that we do, especially since
they're all multiple day labs.
So you will have a lot
of things to write about
in the procedure.
And so you want to keep those
straight between your days.
And this is where your lab
notebook and the notes that you
take in the lab are going to
be super-important and helpful
in writing up what is happening
in this section of the lab.
The way that you write the
whole lab report, but especially
the procedure and
observation section,
is in the third-person
passive voice.
And this feels awkward for
a lot of people at first.
But instead of writing
something like, I
added 5 milliliters of
nitric acid to the copper,
it took this long,
and I used 6.2 molar
nitric acid and
copper shavings, you
would write it in
the passive voice.
So, to a round bottom flask
containing copper metal
shavings was added 5
milliliters of nitric acid.
The acid was added drop-wise
over the course of 15 minutes.
So there are no real
actors in your lab report,
except for the
chemicals themselves.
So the chemical was added.
By who, we don't care.
You want to write in
the passive voice.
And as an example,
here is an article
that was recently
published in JACS,
the Journal of the
American Chemical Society.
And you can see that this is
how a procedural section is
written for something that's
going to be published.
And one of the ways
that you can do it--
you can either say in
the sentences, like,
10 millimoles of
2,4-Dibromobutyryl chloride was
added, or you can put the
quantities in parentheses.
And in this case, they've
chosen to do it in millimolar.
In your lab report, you can use
whatever quantity you measured.
So if you measured it out
in grams or milliliters,
then that's what you should
write in your report here.
So that's an example of
thing-- and something to note.
This didn't copy over well
when I copied and pasted it.
But you should
definitely always make
sure to superscript
and subscript
things as appropriate.
Take the time and do it.
Yeah, that should
go without saying.
And one of the handouts
that I gave you
is also another example
of a procedural section
that has been written for
a lab that you guys are not
going to do.
But it's another example
of how the language can go
and what it looks like
when it's all written.
The next section is the results.
So the results
that you collected
are going to be summarized
in your results section,
obviously.
This is best done using
tables or graphs if you can.
And this is not the place
to analyze your data.
So you don't want to
be making any comments
about it, saying, oh, I
got this terrible yield
of 22% or whatever.
You really want to
write that anywhere.
But here, you're just
presenting your results.
And then you will talk about
them and what they mean
in your discussion section.
So what sort of
results are you going
to have for your ferrocene lab?
And if you're going to
put them in a table, what
would our table look like?
What are some good
headings for the data
that we will have
from ferrocene?
AUDIENCE: Yield?
SARAH HEWETT: Yield.
What units?
AUDIENCE: Grams?
SARAH HEWETT: Grams, sure.
You can do grams, you
can do milligrams,
depending on how successful
your synthesis was.
AUDIENCE: The first column
should be, like, name?
SARAH HEWETT: Yeah,
compound name.
What other data
can we talk about?
All the way on the left.
AUDIENCE: Melting point.
SARAH HEWETT:
Melting point, yeah.
We'll throw that over
here because it's small.
AUDIENCE: Molecular weight?
SARAH HEWETT: Molecular weight
is not necessarily a result.
So that would be
something that you
could include in
your calculations
when you're doing your
theoretical yield calculation,
something like that.
AUDIENCE: RFs.
SARAH HEWETT: RF.
So you could include
that in the table,
but it may be smart to do a
separate table for your RF
values.
But that definitely
should be in there.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I mean,
you could include
qualitative-- like,
appearance, color.
SARAH HEWETT: Yeah.
Color or appearance.
So you can say it was light
orange, dark orange, red.
It was a powder, it was clumpy.
You got big, giant
crystals of it--
whatever you got.
What other information
are we going to get?
Related to yield, but what's
another way to report yield?
AUDIENCE: Percent.
SARAH HEWETT:
Percent yield, yeah.
Excellent.
So this would be a
really great table
to include in your
ferrocene report
with all of this data in it.
Then what compounds are we going
to have all of this information
for?
AUDIENCE: Ferrocene.
SARAH HEWETT: Ferrocene.
What kind of ferrocene?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
crude ferrocene.
SARAH HEWETT: Crude ferrocene.
What?
AUDIENCE: Purified.
SARAH HEWETT:
Purified ferrocene.
And?
AUDIENCE: Acetylferrocene.
SARAH HEWETT:
Acetylferrocene, both crude
and pure of that as well,
pre and post column?
You may not have all of this
data for all these compounds,
but you should be pretty close.
And if you made any
diacetylferrocene,
you can put that in here,
too, if you have enough
to collect off of your column.
And you'll find out next
week if you enough of that.
So yeah, those are your results.
Anything else that
we're missing in terms
of results for this lab?
No, it looks pretty good.
So if you wanted to insert
a graph, which in this case,
we don't really have any
graphs necessarily that
would go into your report.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I was wondering, where
does the calibration come from?
SARAH HEWETT: What
a great question.
So you guys are making
the calibration curve
for your melting points.
Where would you put that?
We have one vote
for calculations,
one vote for appendix.
Any thoughts?
So the things that get
inserted into your results
section, or your
calculation section,
are things that are
very directly related
to the goals of the lab.
So if you need something to
get whatever data that you care
about-- so like in the catylase
that you guys are going
to be doing, you'll need
to make graphs in order
to get some rate constant data.
So those graphs are
super-important to the goal
of the lab.
Is a melting point
calibration curve
very important to our
stated goal of this lab?
Not necessarily, but
we need it in order
to get the data
that we care about.
So that's something that
can go in an appendix.
And that would be an excellent
spot for your melting point
calibration curve, because
just like anything else,
if you put something
in an appendix,
you need to reference
it in your lab.
Because why would you
include it anywhere
if it doesn't
matter for your lab?
Maida?
AUDIENCE: So would the procedure
for that go under procedures,
or would we not include that?
SARAH HEWETT: The procedure
for making the melting point
calibration curve?
That's a good question.
Any thoughts?
Put it in the appendix?
Yeah, so again, that's
something that can probably go
in the appendix, because
it's not super-important
to your actual lab, but--
AUDIENCE: What about in
the procedure section
a list of every
instrumentation we use,
it is typically written in
the synthesis section and then
a list of different techniques.
Can we put melting point
determination in there?
The machine's
calibrated x, y, z.
SARAH HEWETT: Yes, that's
also a good way to do it.
So there's a couple of ways.
So one would be to
put the procedure
in the appendix with the
melting point calibration curve,
and have a note in
your procedure saying,
see appendix for calibration
curve and the procedure
for generating it.
Or when you are making
your procedure section,
you can have different sections
for all of the different things
that we did.
So you would have sections of
the procedure for the synthesis
pieces, and then sections of
the procedure for the techniques
that you use.
And if you wanted to
put a technique section
for the melting
point, then you could
say melting point was
determined this way,
and then talk about how you made
the calibration curve there.
So there's a couple
of ways to do it.
As long as the information is
there and referenced well, then
that is acceptable
So if you are planning to insert
a graph into your lab report,
if you want to put
the calibration
curve or any other
graph that you make
throughout the semester
into your lab report,
you will insert it as a figure.
And the way that you
reference your figures
is that you insert the
figure or the graph
or whatever it may be.
And then you need to
put a caption, which
goes underneath the
figure or the graph.
And even though
this is a graphic,
it's labeled as figure 1.
And then you number your figures
1, 2, 3, 4, or 5, as many
as you have throughout
your lab report.
And then you need some
sort of description
of what the figure is or
what the graph is showing.
And if it's a
graph, then you need
to make sure that
the graph itself
has a title and axes that
are labeled with units.
That goes without saying,
and a legend if you need one.
And then all of that
information also gets
reiterated in the caption.
The caption goes below the
graph, which is important,
because if you're going
to insert a table,
then the tables
also get inserted.
However, they are called
tables, and the caption
goes above the table.
So you want to make sure
when you have your table
that you have all
of your columns
with headings and with
appropriate units,
and if you choose a unit that
gives you a reasonable number
of digits in your data.
And if something is
getting out of hand,
or if you have one
measurement that's
on a different scale
than the others,
use scientific notation.
Or you can change the
units for one column,
but try to avoid that.
So yeah, that's how you insert
a table into your lab report.
Calculations-- so
any time that you
present data that was
not directly measured,
you need to show how
it was calculated
with appropriate units.
So when the data is presented
you should show an equation--
so the general form of the
equation that you're using,
a sample calculation with
one set of your data,
and then the final answer.
So if you're going to be doing
a calculation repeatedly,
like percent yield you're going
to calculate percent yields
for a whole bunch of
different compounds.
You just need to show the
calculation once, and then
just show the yield for
the other three compounds
that you're calculating it for.
If there are
lengthy calculations
that you can do in
an Excel spreadsheet,
then you can include the Excel
spreadsheet in an appendix,
as long as in your report
you have shown a sample
calculation, and the
equations that you're
using to get all of the data
in that Excel spreadsheet.
If you have a lot
of calculations,
you can include
them in an appendix,
as long as the data
is well-labeled,
and the sample calculations
and equations have been shown.
And again, all of this should
be in your report somewhere.
And then if you need to
add more in an appendix,
you can if your report's
getting really long.
So the discussion-- this
is where you finally
get to talk about your
data and what it means.
So you will summarize
your key results.
Explain any
difficulties or errors
that led to erroneous results.
So if you accidentally
spilled some
of your ferrocene
solution, then you
might talk about how
that impacted your yield.
Offer suggestions to
improve the experiment.
So one of them could be
maybe change the glassware
that you're using if you're
spilling a lot of chemicals.
Or if you have an idea
for different chemicals
that we could use
that would be better
for the similar procedure,
that would be a good time
to talk about it, or adjustments
to the length of time
that you do something.
Anything that you can think
of that may improve the lab,
this would be a
nice spot to put it.
And then answer
any questions that
are posed in the lab manual.
There are no questions
in the lab manual
for the ferrocene experiment.
But you'll notice, if you look
at the other labs throughout
later in the semester,
at the end of the lab,
there are a set of
discussion questions
that relate to the
procedures in the data
that you will
collect in the lab.
Do not just answer those
questions in a list.
A lot of them are numbered.
Don't go through and make
your discussion a bulleted
or numbered list of
answers to these questions,
and don't just write one
sentence after the other.
That's very obviously just
answers to the questions.
Your discussion section
should flow nicely.
This will be the longest
section of your lab report,
and it should be the one with
the most thought put into it.
So make it flow like a
nice piece of writing.
Your TAs have to read these.
They will appreciate
them much more
if you write with good
grammar, and in a way that is
intelligent and easy to follow.
The answer should
tell a coherent story
throughout all of
your discussion.
You can talk about
sources of error
that either came from
you or random errors.
And we'll talk about different
types of error again next week.
And then analyze your
data in your errors.
So your calculations should
have already been done.
So do not include
more calculations
in your discussion.
If you need to
calculate something,
go back and do it in
the results section.
But now you want
to analyze the data
and talk about what it means.
So you've reported
your melting point.
You've reported
all of your yields.
You've reported your RF values.
What does it mean?
What does it say about the
success of the experiment?
Go back to your intro
and say, hey, this
is what I said I
was going to do.
Did I do it?
And here is my data
to explain why.
So what can we talk about
in the ferrocene discussion?
AUDIENCE: You get a sense
how our percent yield isn't
100% because of errors,
potentially because you didn't
scrape all the ferrocene off
of the culture dish, something
like that?
SARAH HEWETT: Yeah.
Yeah, so you can talk
about your percent yield.
It's not going to be 100%.
And why might that be?
So different parts
of the procedure,
where did you lose product?
Scraping it out of the round
bottom, that was really hard.
A lot of people were
struggling to get
all their acetylferrocene out
of the round bottom yesterday,
or scraping stuff off of the
ferrocene when you sublimed,
different pieces.
So you can go back
again-- and this
is a good spot when
your notebook is
going to help you a lot.
If you take good
notes in the lab,
then you'll know, oh, yeah.
That's where my product went.
What else can we talk about?
AUDIENCE: After we do
chromatography experiments
we'll have a percentage
of [INAUDIBLE] compounds
and products.
SARAH HEWETT: Yeah, so
after you do your TLC,
you'll have one way to tell how
pure your final mixture was.
Did you still have
ferrocene left
when you thought you only
had made acetylferrocene?
So amounts of
compounds left over.
So you'll have that
information from TLC.
And from your column,
when you run your column,
and you separate
out your ferrocene
and your acetylferrocene, you'll
see how pure your product was.
And you can talk about that
and why you may not have
had a completely pure product.
What else?
So what else is in our
results chart that we have not
discussed over here?
AUDIENCE: Melting ranges.
SARAH HEWETT: Melting point.
And what does that tell us?
AUDIENCE: Same thing-- purity.
SARAH HEWETT: Same thing.
You can get purity.
So was your melting point
too low or a wide range?
What else can your melting point
help you tell, to some extent?
In our case, we're
using it to determine
the identity of our
products, because we
don't have a lot of
really spectroscopic ways
of characterizing this product.
So we are going to use it
to identify your products.
So you can tell us how pure
your product was, and then
compare it to the literature
to see what the identity is.
And hopefully,
your melting points
of ferrocene and acetylferrocene
are not the same.
So you did, in fact have
some evidence that you
made a different compound.
Anything else?
AUDIENCE: Maybe explain
the color and appearance
[INAUDIBLE]
SARAH HEWETT: Yeah.
So you can, again, bring in
some more of your results.
Talk about the color and
the appearance of things.
So your ferrocene and
your acetylferrocene
are different colors.
You can talk about
why that might be,
and how you can use
that to identify
your different compounds,
especially on your TLC plate.
So when you run your
TLC, in your column,
you'll be able to tell your
compounds apart by color--
hopefully.
So yeah, and then again,
if you had any suggestions
for how to improve
the procedure,
those can also go
in your discussion.
If you were doing something
and said, oh, this
would be much better
if we did it this way,
or the sublimation, I found
this cool trick for it,
please tell us.
And perhaps your
genius idea will
help us improve the lab for
future semesters of students.
Then at the end,
there's a conclusion.
So you briefly
summarize your results.
This again is pretty
similar to the abstract.
It'll just be about a paragraph,
maybe a little bit longer.
A statement about whether you
achieve the goals for the lab,
then wrap up your
discussion section
and tie everything together.
Based on the abstract
and the conclusion,
if people read those
two parts, they
should have a generally
pretty good idea
about what happened in the lab.
And if they want details, then
they can read the rest of it.
So conclusion--
again, wrap it all up.
And then once you're
done with all of this,
go back and write your
abstract, because now we
have all of the information
that needs to be neatly
summarized in our abstract.
The very last thing that we need
to talk about is references.
So at the end of
your report, you
need to list all the
sources that you use,
but you also need to
cite them in the text.
And this should not
be anything new.
Do not use Wikipedia
as a reference.
You can cite the lab
manual and the lectures
that's a good idea.
And then there's also a
handout that I gave you
as to the format of how to cite
different commonly-referenced
sources, like books,
articles, things like that.
The ACS Style Guide
also has information
about how to cite
any type of reference
that you could
ever need to cite.
The in-text citations,
there are three ways
that you can do them.
So if you're planning to cite
this article in your lab report
for some reason, then you
would have a sentence.
And then the first
way to do it is
to include the author's
name and then the year.
You can also have
a numbered list,
and you superscript at
the end of the sentence.
Or the last way is
to put the number
of the reference in
parentheses in italics
at the end of the sentence.
So up to you.
All three ways are
ACS-approved, whichever one
you find the easiest
or most familiar.
Appendices, we talked
about this a little bit.
It's a really good way to
include relevant information
that doesn't fit well into
the body of the lab report,
or maybe isn't the most
important thing to the goal
that you're trying to achieve.
They don't count
towards your page limit.
So if your lab report
is getting long,
and you can find things that
would go in the appendix,
that's not a bad thing.
Don't put stuff that
should be in the lab
report in the appendix just
for the sake of giving yourself
extra space in the lab report.
We will take points
off for that.
Appendices have a
number and a title.
So appendix 1, and then you
would say what's in appendix 1.
Refer to that in the text of
the report like anything else.
The format-- this is probably
the most important thing
that you guys care about.
There's a 10 page limit,
plus or minus 2 pages.
So if yours is significantly
shorter than 10 pages
or significantly longer, then
you will start to lose points.
10 pages should be the
right amount of space
to talk about all of the
results in all of these labs.
1 and 1/2 line spacing in
Word, one inch margins,
12 point Times New Roman
font-- pretty standard stuff.
And then print it out.
If we want an electronic
version, we will request it.
But most of the grading
is done by hand.
So we print it out, and we will
give you back the hard copy
the following week.
Ethics-- we've talked
about this before already,
but do your own work.
Don't use a lab reports
from prior students.
Do not copy and paste
anything that you did not
write yourself.
Cite your sources, and do not
go looking for similar reports
on the internet.
Some of the labs
that we do here are
similar to labs they
do other places.
Some of them are
wildly different,
so you won't find
anything, anyway.
The TAs and instructors are
here to help you succeed.
So we're the ones who are
grading your lab reports.
So instead of going, looking
up some random report
from some other person at
a different institution
on the internet,
come talk to us.
We are the ones who know
how we will be grading it,
what we are looking for, and
what you did specifically,
so we can help you
write your lab report
the best way possible.
Here is the point breakdown
for how most of the lab reports
are graded.
You can see that the discussion
and the results portion
are weighted more heavily
than the rest of it.
In the ester lab, you will
be identifying an unknown.
And so that's only
for one lab, which
is why the range is on here.
It varies from lab to lab based
on how much time and effort
you're going to be putting
into each of the sections.
Submission and
grading-- so labs are
due at the start of on the
dates listed in the lab manual.
There is a locked box outside
of the stockroom in the lab,
and that's where you
will turn your lab in.
Do not turn your lab into
your mailbox or to my mailbox
or to John's mailbox.
It goes into the lock box,
then the TAs will collect them.
They will grade them, and
they will be returned one week
from when you turned it in.
So if have a Monday,
Wednesday lab,
if you turn your
lab in on Monday,
you will be graded
the following Monday.
When you get it back on
that following Monday,
you have one week to dispute
any points with your TA.
So they'll give you back the
lab report with their comments
on it.
And if you disagree with
something, talk to you TA.
Try to figure out why they
graded it the way they did.
If you guys can
resolve whatever point
conflict you think
that you're having,
if the TA made a mistake,
if you made a mistake
and didn't realize
it, figure it out.
If you can't figure
it out, then you
can submit your
report to me, and I
will regrade the entire thing
for either more or less points,
depending on how well you
wrote your lab report.
So the last resort
is giving it to me.
And then grades will be
posted on Stellar one
week after the
reports are returned,
once any point disputes
have been resolved,
so that you'll be able to
keep track of your scores.
Looking ahead, the final
report is an oral report.
It'll be a chalk talk,
so no PowerPoints.
You'll get a chalkboard
and any handouts
that you want to bring.
It'll be you and
your TAs, and you
have to convince them that
you understand the experiment
and your data analysis.
So this will be for the
final report of the semester.
So it's a long ways off, but I
wanted to give you a heads up.
Just something to
be thinking about.
It's the same information
that's in a written report.
It's just a different
way of presenting it,
and it should not be scary.
You guys know what you're doing.
And by that point,
you'll definitely
know what you're doing.
And the TAs are, obviously, here
to help you guys with anything
that you need.
And there will be
a couple of class
lectures later in the semester,
where the TAs will give you
beautiful examples of good oral
reports and bad oral reports.
So if you want to come see
your TA's acting skills,
put that on your calendar.
Does anyone have any
questions about anything
that we have talked about today?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: For the equations
and figures that we draw
[INAUDIBLE] lab
report, or should we
draw or scan them, and then
hand in the scanned drawing?
SARAH HEWETT: You should
scan them in and put them
in your lab report, and
print it out all together.
Try not to write extra notes
on the end afterwards, yeah.
We want to have everything
printed so that it doesn't
get confused with the TAs
notes and people adding things
after they've been graded.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So you talked
about having office hours
before having the
labs turned in?
SARAH HEWETT: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Are those on Stellar?
SARAH HEWETT: They will be.
So yeah, there will
be office hours
before every lab
report is turned in.
And the TAs are going to--
they'll be posted on Stellar
next week once we schedule it
with all the TAs.
Great.